[Musique]
et la culture ce n'est pas forcément
pour les plus grands à saint quentin en
yvelines
on l'a bien compris le rendez-vous des
juniors d'aujourd'hui d'aujourd'hui va
aux gens qu ami pendant deux semaines
c'est babillage le festival pour les
tout petits qui commença dès la
naissance les médiathèques de
l'agglomération ont concocté un planning
qui fourmille de petits rendez vous pour
les bambins
cette année c'est la sixième édition et
ça parle de l'image fixe du pop up vous
savez qu'elle peut être ces livres qui
une fois ouvert présente leur image en
volume en 3d et c'est la spécialité de
l'invité d'honneur philippe eu j'ai
écouté en particulier il fait des livres
pop up
donc il y en a qui sont faits par en
plus gros noms qui sont faits par année
du cac mais il ya aussi des livres qui
sont vraiment des objets d'art et un
enfant certains à l'image c'est parce
qu'il est fait chez lui un exemple être
très très limité c'est magnifique c'est
magnifique ça donne envie celle approche
aussi du congé de l'approché de
l'histoire même pour le plus grand ça
rappelle aussi des souvenirs on en avait
tous un quand on était enfant donc le
compte c'est le pape vont se décliner en
plusieurs rendez vous pendant ces quinze
jours il va y avoir des spectacles il va
y avoir des comptes ça se passe
notamment de leur os canto qui
médiathécaires ceux là sont à vivre d un
an
la conteuse catherine la vesle elle vous
entraîne dans les aventures de drôles de
personnages qui sont sortis tout droit
d'un chapeau et les futurs mélomanes
pourront aussi s'amuser que les mots et
les rythmes grâce à l'association portée
musicale
alors il y a des dizaines de rendez vous
pour être sûr de ne rien manquer il faut
pas hésiter à consulter le programme
il est accessible sur le site internet
des médiathèques les parents donc ne
sont pas oubliés car une conférence est
organisée alors là la rencontre elle est
prévue le mardi 10 avril de 14 heures à
17 heures les parents vont ainsi pouvoir
échanger que l'invité d'honneur philippe
huchet il sera accompagné de
l'association mixage fou il permet
parleront notamment des nouvelles formes
d'interaction que les tout-petits autour
de l'image comme sur le thème avec la
cette fois les tapis enchanté ce sont
des tapis interactif qui prennent vie
grâce à un projecteur de vidéos dont
pour de nombreux rendez vous les
inscriptions sont indispensables comme
on l'a dit n'oubliez pas de vous
inscrire sur le site internet
cette sixième édition de babillages se
déroule jusqu'au 14 avril
toutes les informations sont disponibles
sur le site internet avec babillage la
parole est donnée aux tout-petits merci